you mentioned taking care of both lines
we talked earlier about the buccaneers
likely not being in the jj watt pursuit
because they have their own guys that
they want to keep and they've said
they will try to keep if not definitely
will keep and damage and sue one of them
speaking to albert breer of si.com
earlier this week sue said my goal is to
come back and have an opportunity to go
win another championship me and tom
brady spoke the other day about that
opportunity as well as with gm jason
light i don't know if you saw a parade
celebration on that podium coach bruce
aryan said i'm not going anywhere and
he's usually a man of his word again
they can't go sign jj want they can't
sign whoever else happens to fall out of
the sky because they have to keep sue
they have to keep shaq barrett they have
to keep levante david they have to keep
chris godwin i don't know that they can
do that one but they have to at least
try to keep that defense together
because they've said these guys are
coming back and it wasn't just some
drunken moment even if it was and maybe
it was it's going to resonate with the
audience and those guys are thinking
we're going to get taken care of we're
going to get our reward for helping this
team to its first super bowl win in 18
years
you know mike as you look at even
with the economic downturn with the cap
um
you really have to look at a couple of
guys at the wide receiver position alan
robinson and chris godwin who i'm not
saying they're equal but i think if they
were on the open market they would get
a lot of traffic and obviously each team
has the ability to use the franchise tag
on those players but the other day i was
i was talk i just called bruce arians
about something on sunday
and um you know we were talking he
believes that they can keep both
shaq barrett and chris godwin now
naturally he's going to say that
but i think that he truly does believe
deep down that they can keep both
the problem is you have to ask yourself
in an environment like this one okay
think about it in an environment like
like this one
shaq barrett chris godwin are both
probably close to
19 or 20 million dollar players per year
and ask yourself this question
particularly if you're going to get team
friendly deals from both gronk and
antonio brown
okay
who do you keep if you have a choice
shaq barrett or chris godwin and i ask
you that question mike florio tell me
are you you're keeping shaq barrett
without question and then when godwin
leaves and people say well i i thought
you were going to keep god when all
arians has to say is he wanted too much
we tried he wanted too much we couldn't
do it and and you just shrug and you
move on but i i don't know why they
would even try to keep chris godwin when
you consider someone is going to come
along presumably in a in a different
year i'd say absolutely someone's going
to come along and throw a premium at
chris godwin just to rip him away from
the
buccaneers but this year i don't know
maybe it won't be a premium because
maybe they'll look at it and say i you
know our money is better spent elsewhere
but if they've got antonio brown who
will most likely come back unless
russell wilson really rattles cages in
seattle to get them to make a run at
brown because that's a guy that russell
wanted last year miller and tyler
johnson they still have mike evans i
just think that godwin becomes a luxury
you shouldn't even try to afford because
it is going to affect your ability to
keep key defensive pieces in place so
without question i'd keep shaq barrett
over chris godwin peter
well you mentioned a guy right there who
in my opinion
is i don't know if you can call him a
star in the future but i think he's
going to be a an above average nfl wide
receiver and that's tyler johnson the
rookie fifth round pick from minnesota
who who made a huge impact on their team
made a great catch at green bay in a
vital spot of the game in the fourth
quarter
or in new orleans excuse me and then at
green bay who did tom brady throw the
ball to just inside the two-minute
warning when they needed to extend the
drive and run out the clock against the
green bay packers
they threw it he threw it to tyler
johnson who was interfered with when
when kevin king grabbed his jersey or
his t-shirt whatever it was
but
look at look at what tom brady did on
two huge calls one in the divisional
game one in the championship game he
found tyler johnson to me it was
reminiscent of him looking for malcolm
mitchell and chris hogan in the super
bowl win over atlanta why is he throwing
to them well because i trust them
tom brady is not throwing the ball to
anybody
in a huge moment of a playoff game
unless he trusts them so i totally agree
with you mike i'm franchising shaq
barrett i'm trying to work out a
long-term deal and if you can get godwin
for below
what he might make somewhere else great
if not sometimes you just have to say
goodbye
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports